all right so
yeah so today we're going to continue
with discussing circuit complexity and
connections uh between complexity and
algorithms
okay so this is the much anticipated
part too
so uh last time we were talking about a
connection between
circuit sat and circuit lower bounds
we were just describing at a high level
the connection
so
as we were saying a slightly faster
round for c set one running
and say 2 to the n over n in the 10 for
all polynomial sizes
would get us
a function in an x that does not have
polynomial size circuits
okay
and
so we
discussed that this
connection is quite generic that
depending on what circuit class you can
solve the sat problem for you will get a
different kind of circuit lower bound
okay
so if you get a circuit set algorithm
running in this much time you get a
strong lower bound now it would be
weaker to give a formula sat algorithm
because formulas are for a special case
of circuits so if you merely
could just get a faster formula set
algorithm you would prove formula lower
bounds for
functions in x
and
and so on like if you had acc said
algorithms which i sketched a couple
lectures ago
you would have lower bounds
a function in x does not have small acc
circuits
and i also discussed
that you don't have to solve the sat
problem in this full
generalization you just have to
distinguish between
unsatisfiable circuits and ones which
have say at least half of their
assignments satisfying deterministically
again this is a problem which can be
solved efficiently with randomness just
by random sampling inputs
and you know seeing if any of them are
satisfiable okay
that would still
get you
in x naught and p poly
okay
so
all right and so we'll see the proof
that x is not in acc uh later on
here
so the converse
that so we before we were talking about
how circuit analysis algorithms imply
circular balance the converses can lower
bounds imply algorithms
and
so roswell has been talking at length
about these kinds of connections
connections between circuit lower bounds
and de-randomization
so
given a circuit lower balance you can
de-randomize randomized ions make them
deterministic
so for example
x non-mp poly implies bbp is in sub
exponential time very infinitely often
so but for restricted circuit classes
sometimes the techniques that were used
to prove circuit lower balance so
in order to prove a circuit lower bound
some property some nice property of that
circuit was found and that nice property
can often be leveraged to get a set
algorithm for the same circuit class
so here's just a canonical example of
this if we look at boolean formulas over
and or not
the ans and ors have fan and two this is
the class of demorgan formulas
uh way back in the 60s sibotoskaya
showed that the mod 2 function the
parity function in bits can't be
computed
with essentially into the 1.5 size
boolean formulas with and or not gates
using the so-called random restriction
method so if you
if you randomly set
a randomly chosen subset of variables
into the formula and simplify it
you actually find that the formula
shrinks by
some
non-trivial amount
okay and so the thing is if you set for
example all but one of the bits
to a formula that's supposed to compute
the mod 2 function it better be that the
whole formula doesn't simplify to a
constant
because
even if i see if i set even
n minus 1 bits on something computing
the mod 2 function the last bit will
still determine the output
right the last bit will fi will tell me
what whether the sum is even or odd
so if i choose like n minus
one of uh or if i choose one of the
inputs at random and set all the others
randomly
if that whole thing shrinks like
simplifies to a constant function it
could not compute mod 2 and essentially
that's what sabotovskaya showed was that
that formulas of of this size
if you
sort of hit them with a random
restriction on all but one of the bits
it's going to simplify to a constant
with high probability okay so we
couldn't compute the mod 2 function for
example but this has
had been improved to uh in squared size
but uh
in 2011 rahul santana used strengthening
of subatovskaya's argument to show that
the sat problem for linear size boolean
formulas with n and or gates can be
solved and lessened to the end time
and the idea
in retrospect is sort of
a concentration version of the random
restriction limit so
really what rahul is doing is taking a
very natural algorithm for branching you
pick a variable that occurs most often
and you try to set it to false and
you're encouraged to try to set it to
true you recurs you do some basic
simplifications like if if you have an
or of a variable and it's negations like
that then you simplify it
and what you end up saying is that uh if
i
if i hit a
formula an inside form with a random
restriction
and leave some variables unset not only
does it simplify to a constant with you
know some probability it simplifies the
constant with super high probability so
if you think about it from the point of
view of a branching algorithm um what
i'm saying is that
like if i like on the vast majority of
the branches all but exponential small
fraction of the branches the entire
thing is going to simplify to a cost in
which case i would have determined
whether or not the formula was sat on
that branch
and so the the branching ends early in
this in this respect so like setting a
bunch of variables at random makes the
things simplify to a constant fast then
you don't have to branch so far
that's that's the main intuition behind
what rahul did strengthening this
uh the ingredients using this little
amount and this has since been
strengthened by many others the the same
basic intuition
so for example there's a whole paper
that that
gives lots of different arguments to the
sky
uh with valentine and antonina and
is there anyone else from here in the
audience i don't know
yeah but uh
jen being the main author so mining
circuit lower bound proofs for meta
algorithm so
uh so go check out their paper there's
lots of
results of this kind you can kind of
systematically take circular bound
proofs uh strengthen a little bit and
then get
things like set algorithms
or as they like to call them compression
algorithms of it and so one thing i
would like to just note
in passing is that you can also bind
circuit lower bound proofs to the ideas
behind them to get algorithms for
problems that have nothing to do with
set nothing to do with circuits they're
actually problems that people and
algorithms want to solve
or people who you know study you go to
soda all the time really want to solve
so for example if you
uh study this polynomial method of
response malinsky
which i have this one slide outline
of how rosborough swalinsky can take
constant depth circuits and
translate them into low degree
polynomials you can use this to get
faster algorithms for many other
problems which don't have to do with
circuits
so for example
you can use this to solve the all-pair
shortest path problem in cubed over
about to the square root log n time
virginia discussed this briefly but she
didn't
say really how it was obtained and it
was really obtained by taking one of the
slides from
right from what i was talking about for
ac zero set algorithm
and basically applying it in the right
way to solve all pairs shortest paths
okay
so other things you can do is like solve
this
orthogonal vectors problem or
equivalently find a disjoint pair of
sets in a set system
compute partial match queries evaluate a
cnr formula um you can find longest
common substring that don't cares
in about n squared over two the square
root log n time where n is the length
of the two
strings so um
you can solve
a zero one integer programming
much faster than to the end time you
can't get one point nine in time that
would contradict stronger th but you can
get something much faster than two to
the n
and recently with josh allman we
we found some even stronger
results
we basically proved some new
probabilistic polynomial
theorems and use this to find the
closest pair of points in the hemming
metric so
i can i will
say a little more detail
what it is we
actually we all leave this here for him
uh
we actually proved
so in this
um
in this problem finding the closest pair
of points it's been studied
for many many decades i think it it
appears uh
in
minsky and paper it's a book on
perceptrons from the 60s
so
you have let's say
two kinds of points say n red points and
n blue points
and let's say they're in
c log n dimensions okay now these points
are in the boolean hypercube so they're
all zero one
okay
they have c log n dimensions that's sort
of the k the where c is greater than one
that's the case where it starts to
become interesting
and you want to find uh a red point
and a blue point
with uh minimum hamming distance okay
so just find you know the ones with the
fewest number of bits which differ
all right
so this problem comes up in many many
different contexts
what we can show using uh probabilistic
polynomials
is that
sort of every
constant c
you can
find this closest pair
and hemming
metric
and
n the 2 minus
order
log c
okay
so
n squared times the dimension would be
the naive way to do it okay
if you had a really large dimension you
could use a matrix multiplication to get
like n
you know
uh something like n squared you know
maybe or into the omega or something
like that like eve no matter what the
dimension was using matrix small but
here you can actually get something
truly subquadratic as long as c is some
constant
okay
and actually the dependence is not so
bad it means log
of that
okay
so and this really comes from
finding a probabilistic polynomial for
the majority function
so this is
so this is a
with uh josh
i i just wanted to emphasize that
uh
you could you know study circuit
complexity you know i mean if you just
purely interested in finding better
algorithms you might find a better oven
for your pet problem and it may have
nothing to do with circuit set or
or or anything like that on the face of
it
but you know uh
to to a complexity theorist you know
everything looks like a certain kind of
circuit so
so that's maybe the the trick behind
most of these results okay
if you look at things in the right way
you can turn them into circuits
okay
are there any questions about like the
the
if you want a little more detail yeah
a little bit about what all those
problems have in common
well what they have in common
um what
yeah sure yeah yeah so
so a lot of them are
are kind of exhaustive search type
problems like here for example
um
here you're doing you're really doing
some kind of computation over and over
and over namely computing the hamming
distance
of a pair of vectors well actually you
can also think of it as doing another
kind of computation over and over for a
group of vectors here and a group of
vectors here i'm trying to find what is
the pair with the minimum hamming
distance okay so this is some repeated
subcomputation and this repeated
subcomputation can be written in a very
nice form so
for example
if i have like a group of s vectors here
and another group of s vectors here
and i want to know
is there a vector here and a vector here
that have hamming distance uh
let's say
at least k
then i could write that circuit
you know circuit wise
as like or over all s squared pairs
picking one from here and one from there
of a certain kind of gate let's say if
i'm trying to find hemi distance at most
k i'm going to have some gate
let's say at most k which um
it's going to output 1 if and only if
the
sum of the bits
is in most k okay
and then i'm going to take an xor so
this is xor
of
you know whatever bits here
corresponding whatever bits here right
this this is just the
definition of of hamming distance
all right
so so i'll get a circuit that looks a
bit like that
okay so what uh josh and i show us how
to take a circuit like this
and convert it
with decent probability into a
polynomial like a just a an xor of ands
of a certain form which is correct on a
given
input with with decent probability okay
then we take this polynomial and we
evaluate it over all the possible groups
okay and that that uses
um a fast matrix multiplication so given
a given a certain polynomial and given
so now you've got like n over s
different groups here and over s
different groups we can
evaluate this thing over all
pairs of groups which is like n squared
over s squared different pairs
efficiently okay and we can set s to be
about n to the
one over order log see
and still get this to work so in all of
these is fast matrix multiplication the
thing that you end up reducing things to
um so
basically
and for most of these
yes um
if you
there you could always use fast major
small if you want to on any of these
for for ones like zero one integer lp
there and you can also apply this sort
of thing even to sat itself
you can get away with uh something more
like an fft actually exactly this
algorithm i said before about evaluating
a multi-linear polymer this is simple
divide and conquer you can use a simple
divide and conquer in some cases
depending on how your problem is set up
any more questions
yeah but that's the key idea is to
identify some repeated subcomputation
express it in some nice
circuit form then use this
uh polynomial method to convert that to
a polymer now you could just say why do
i even have a circuit at all why not
just convert it to a panel directly well
i mean i just
for the purposes of thinking about it
that's that's what we do i mean
obviously if you could just take the
whatever subcomputation you've got and
somehow turn it
directly into a nice polynomial form
that would be even better
just for the purpose of thinking about
the problem
is easier for us to first get a circuit
doing the thing that obviously does the
thing and then convert it
okay
okay
so so i want to talk a bit about how
circuit lower bounds can sometimes be
equivalent to circuit analysis
algorithms
so you know this is where the
red and blue really mix to become purple
so
russell talks
uh quite a bit about this so i'm only
going to talk about it at a high level
i mean
but
it turns out that i guess this material
is deep enough that
russell and i can say
mathematically the same thing yet uh in
english say totally different things so
so
so well maybe not this statement but the
next one okay i go whatever this is i
have a different way of stating what it
is so
um but it's equivalent i'm pretty sure
okay so
so i like to think of this work of
russell and valentin and avi a while
back so they show that there are
non-trivial algorithms for the circuit
approximation probability problem so
recall this is you're given a circuit
you want to deterministically compute uh
some approximation to the fraction of
satisfying assignments okay so you you
can think of it as trying is some
stronger version of trying to
distinguish between unset circuits
completely and circuits if you're like
at least half satisfying okay half a
second
so this is true if and only if an x is
not be poly and of course like all the
technicalities are shoved into what
that what non-trivial means
okay but the what's very nice here is
that right it's an algorithm design
problem like
taking a circuit telling me something
about the fraction of the satisfying
assignments
and if you sort of look at it in the
right way it is absolutely equivalent to
proving circuit lower bounds this in x
naught and p pi
okay so what does non-trivial mean and
that will occupy the rest of the slide
okay
so
so um
so first uh
it's going to be a non-deterministic
algorithm for cap so it's going to in
other words make some guesses along the
way
in every single
leaf of this non-deterministic branching
where it stops it's either going to say
reject
or it's going to give you
a good answer it's going to give you a
value that is actually an approximation
to the problem okay so non-terms of
government is non-trivial for cap
if for every epsilon this algorithm a on
a circuit c runs in
two to the end of the epsilon time on
circuits of size n and uses in the
epsilon bits of advice
so it's actually a bit non-uniform
itself so to describe
the circuit a which will be right on
inputs of linkedin you need into the
epsilon bits to describe that algorithm
so there's some epsilon bits of advice
being stuck in
and you think it's specifying the
program
that a is going to run okay
and then uh okay so the second condition
is that this
uh thing works for infinitely many
uh circuit sizes n so for infinite many
n
there's at least one accepting
computation path
on this algorithm so this is a
non-intermediate algorithm so
it's starting
you know somewhere and it's guessing a
bunch of stuff guessing a bunch of stuff
there's at least one accepting path
okay frankly many in there's at least
one accepting path for all circuits of
size n okay and every accepting path
actually outputs an answer to the
problem it outputs a value v that's in
one tenth of the acceptance probability
of the circuit which is what you which
is what you want in the cap problem okay
so so for amply mini circuit sizes
it works it does the job
and it runs and selects central time
with
you know this little extra into the
epsilon bits specifying the program
being run and it's non-deterministic
okay i think that's
that's it those are all the conditions
okay but you an algorithm of this kind
exists
if and only if an x is not np poly
okay
um
and it is really along
this similar kinds of lines as we've
been talking about like
um you can think of it as like the
algorithm playing some game with the
circuits and either the circuits when or
the algorithms when if the algorithm
wins
then nx is not np poly the circuits win
and x is np poly and there isn't an
algorithm
so why can't you just try all the
all strings of advice here
oh
because that advice is difficult to
verify to check
it's difficult to check
um
so
if you try to run it on all the
different advice for some of the advice
strings there might not be an accepting
problem computation
even even then drawing on all the string
device you have to run something to
check that the advice is good and
checking even checking the advice is
good it seems hard
yeah i mean there are actually technical
ways to get rid of this advice but if
you like
um on the next slide
but
but uh
those those become even more convoluted
i think yeah yeah yeah if you change cap
to like circuit class cap do you get an
x not in that circuit class
uh yes i think so
i think so yeah i think it works like
this
properties but okay yeah but but all the
ones we even like like yeah it wouldn't
like necessarily preserve exactly say
the depth or something other thing right
but uh
yeah now the but the next uh
slide it does have this property like
for even
uh i don't think
i mean if there are any closure
properties required they're extremely
minimal i haven't really they thought
about it um okay any more questions
about
this statement
okay so um so something i proved which
i believe is supposed to be equivalent
to this
is
uh there are non-trivial algorithms for
the minimum circuit size problem if and
only if nx is not mp poly so
um so you can think of actually natural
properties really
i think the previous lecture i haven't
mentioned this says natural properties
as being
pretty good algorithms for the minimum
circuit size problem right their natural
properties are these things that
take truth tables of functions input the
same kind of input as this minimum
circuit size problem
and they tell you something non-trivial
about the circuit complexity okay for a
natural property it would be that on a
random string
it will say hard
okay with decent probability and on all
the strings with low circuit complexity
whatever that means you know depending
on what you're trying to prove or about
against it will say easy okay so it sort
of just returns a single bit
you know hard or easy
and
and it runs in polynomial time
okay
so so what do you mean by non-trivial
here so
um as russell was saying like this this
kind of thing
so without the barely
this kind of thing
needs
to work
on uh
one over
to the order n
fraction
of
inputs let's say in bit functions okay
so these are to the end bit strings
and we're just going to get rid of this
condition
and we're going to also add some
infinitely often stuff
and then all of a sudden just having
something
so basically having a polynomial time
algorithm that's useful instantly often
is going to be equivalent to nx sine p
poly
so
so we say that algorithm a is
non-trivial for the minimum circuit size
problem
if for all constants k
this algorithm
on the a truth table
f runs in polynomial time so let's say 2
to the n
is the you know size of f only
boolean function f to the n bits and it
uses in bits of advice
now if you allow the algorithm to run on
things which are not of link to the end
and it's sort of truncated things are
rounded up to the nearest power to the
end you could actually get rid of this
advice but you know that's
that's just the extra point okay if
you're worried about advice there are
ways to sort of get around it okay
and
for employment in
this algorithm is going to
to be non-trivial it's going to work so
for there's going to be a some boolean
function of to the n bits on which it
outputs one so think of one is saying
hard
and on all functions computable with a
polynomial size circuits this in the
case i circuit it's going to output 0.
it's going to say it's easy
you see this is like very very weak so
instead of saying it needs to work on a
good fraction of the inputs i'm just
requiring it works on one
just works has to work on one function
as to say at least one function is hard
and all the easy things are easy and i
don't know about the rest and i'm doing
this for infinitely many
uh n okay
um and but i run in paul real time just
as girlfriend rudiger would have liked
okay
all right
and this uh turns out to be
absolutely equivalent to nximp poly
and
uh yeah i think if you look at what
russell was arguing in the right way
yeah
you will you will see this i mean
i think it's more less a restatement it
just you know yeah and they're in
different terms
um
okay
yeah so the main conscious is natural
proofs that natural proofs would require
that uh for a good fraction of boolean
functions of thing outputs one that's
really the the the only difference i
mean for at least like having a
polynomial time constructive thing with
a say
log size of input bits of advice
okay
all right so
um
so
because i was going to spend more time
talking about this
because i saw russell's lecture i began
modifying my slides and so i'm going to
talk about
uh
something else
as well it's some recent work with one
of my phd students bryn mawr chapman
um
it's a it's a little
um
mind-bending so i'll try to go a bit
slower i mean
depending on how you look at it's either
mind-bending or it's trivial so but i
think at the beginning it will be
so the idea is to think of lower bounds
in some kind of dual way as a as a
design problem where you're trying to
design certain data sets that are good
for testing whether circuits compute a
function okay i'll just go slow here so
so this is work joint work with bitmore
chapman it is a new kind of equivalence
between algorithms and complexity
the whole idea behind these kinds of
equivalences really is to try to remove
this mentality
that lower
bounds or something you know in
something so non-constructive that like
there is an algorithmic constructive way
of looking at lower bounds there is
something you get there is some object
you get from proving a lower bound and
now what is it right so all these kind
of results are trying to do this this is
of a similar flavor
um so okay so let f be some
function we'd like to compute initially
f is just
over infinite
input
so let c be some simple class of boolean
circuits now we want to sort of test
whether a given a circuit from this
class is computing our desired function
on some slice
of that function depending on the number
of inputs to our circuit
so we're going to define a problem of
this kind so
we define c test for f to be the
following problem okay so our input is
going to be a circuit c
from this class
and we'll let n of c be the number of
inputs to c okay so that's just given as
part of the input of the problem
there's some number n of inputs of that
thing what we want to decide
is whether c computes f
on uh all in bit
n of c bit strings
okay so like i give you the circuit that
and it has the number of inputs i want
to know does it compute f on the slice
yes or no
right so
this is extremely well motivated problem
obviously uh like we think of it f is
some specification something we would
like to compute and we wanted to verify
if c meets the specification okay as
given
all right
so
so it's another kind of meta-algorithmic
problem
that hasn't really i mean i haven't
found much literature on it i would be
happy to
to uh
uh know of uh more references about it
so this is like you you think of that as
some fixed function so for every class
of functions yeah there is a c test for
f for every fixed circuit class and for
every fixed function
this is your problem yeah yeah
yeah you could yeah you could ask you
know you could ask um to see compute the
you know whatever like uh they're all
zeros function
right right and it becomes that becomes
a sat problem right yeah yeah this is
computes the all zeros function here
for to give a specific example
right
so if you compute all zeros function is
unset right this that's the same
right
all right so this uh the problem stated
again
so so how am i going to measure the
complexity of such a problem
well uh we were thinking about it well
this is kind of a problem
where
um
so at the beginning we would like to
compute a function f
by giving you a circuit and that's our
computer and then we're going to get
inputs
and it's going to give us the thing so
what we're going to do is we're going to
flip inputs and programs here so the
circuit used to be the program now it's
the input
we're going to gauge
the complexity of this test problem
by measuring the number of inputs needed
to test if a given circuit computes the
function okay so now the inputs are
becoming the program
and so we call this data complexity okay
so
uh the data complexity
yes yes yes
if a given circuit
yeah so this is so these are inputs to c
so think of these as nfc bit strings
for different uh c's yeah
yes yes yes you're given a well before
the only thing you're really given here
so maybe when i give the definition you
will see what's there you're given one
parameter basically you're given the
circuit size
and now you have to prepare this
collection of inputs it's going to work
on all size s circuits you don't have
the number of inputs
you have the circuit size
and this is actually a very subtle but
uh
key point to the thing so the data
complexity of this test problem is going
to be
some function
actually yeah t so t of s is going to be
the minimum number of labeled examples
so i'm just going to give you a label
example this one i'll give you x an
input and give you f of x the output
okay give you some number of labeled
examples
and i want to know what's the minimum
number necessary and sufficient to
determine for every c of size s whether
c computes f on all of its relevant
inputs right so for every c there's some
number of inputs to it
i want to know what's the minimum number
of labeled examples
uh necessarily efficient for size s so
the only parameter here is the circuit
size s okay so
i'm i'm going to have to
give you examples
for you know different
links of inputs
right like
like for all the different n of c there
could be and i'm going to have to give
you some x's of that nfc length and
because another you know say in prime
length
but i don't know what's the total number
the minimum number of label examples
that will work for every circuit of size
s no matter how many inputs it has
okay
all right so this is also well motivated
right so small data complexity
means that we can rapidly determine if a
given circuit
computes f in fact this is often the way
programs are tested in practice just
running a bunch of inputs
make sure you get our help but okay
this is like a formalization of this
like of the sort of quick and dirty
testing like uh just try a bunch of
inputs and outputs and see if they work
okay i want the minimum number of things
so
so and all i've got to go on is the the
circuit size so every the only thing i
know in advance is like with the circuit
sizes i gave you a budget of s gates go
make a circuit maybe i don't even know i
don't even know how many inputs you're
going to be able to stick at the bottom
well in fact that determines the circuit
complexity right so that so this is this
is intimately related to the circuit
complexity uh the data complexity
um
but it's at least this sort of clear at
a high level i think i have a yet
another slide that gives the definition
too but yeah
this is more analogous to like a hitting
set
than
yeah you want to hit the circuits that
don't compute it in a certain sense
yeah for all the circuits that don't
compute it you want to have some
label example that that that trick so
that fools are like oh oops you got the
wrong answer yeah
examples or non-adaptive oh uh i i just
made we just said in a non-adaptive way
you could have some sort of adaptive
kind of tree thing uh but you could just
take the
as soon as you see an example where c of
x is different from f of x you're done
yeah yeah so your tree would look like
that to me like kind of like a line so
that's true yeah
so that would be interesting for maybe
some approximation point of view if you
want to know if the circuit
approximately gets it or something right
yeah yeah so what's the connection to
machine learning here because you get a
lot labeled examples and then you're
somehow yeah yeah so i mean there is
some connection uh to machine learning
so but it's often like done in a
different
way like in machine learning
you don't know what the what the program
is you don't know what the function is
okay you want to learn what the function
is from the examples
here the function is like part of the
definition of the problem
now you want to like talk about programs
all the possible programs that could
compute the function and do it so like
right you you so there's this notion of
teaching dimension which is for like
concept classes and stuff but yeah they
these things are like just more or less
orthogonal as far as i can tell
because
because the function is unknown and you
want to figure out what it is basically
machine learning yes
isn't it
just a program verification problem yes
yes yes it's like a it's a program
verification problem it's not entirely
black box because of this s
because of the circuit size s
yeah that that's what makes it not in
black box well i mean you know when
you're given a program you kind of have
it's going to be of a certain size
exactly so i i yeah so so it seems
almost as black box as you could be but
it's not exactly like it actually it's
like the minimum amount of information
for that you get a non-trivial notion
i'm going to argue this is non-trivial
yeah
um are you looking at
uniform or non-uniform
so given ask do you have to be able to
compute the set of examples oh no it's
just the minimum number of label
examples totally non-uniform you know so
i don't know you know they just dropped
down from heaven just like the circuits
do not you know foreign circuits
yeah
yeah
yeah i've been putting computability
balance on them would be interesting
thing like sort of how that relates to
uniform circuits i haven't even thought
about this problem neither has been more
than
okay yeah yeah
okay
all right uh
okay so
so here's an informal statement of the
theorem we can prove so for every
function
okay
lower bounds on the data complexity
of testing
for that function for any given circuit
class really
are equivalent to upper bounds
unnecessary complexity of the function
okay
so if you lower bound if you show that
you need at least so much data as a
function of the circuit size to test it
you have given an upper bound on the
circuit complexity
okay and just to restate that you know
for maximum emphasis upper upper bounds
data complexity
are equivalent to lower balance and
series so so if you want to prove
lower bounds
you just have to give
nice
data test sets okay just show there is a
data test set that is that is not too
large okay this is something that's
constructive you could lay out and you
could potentially verify
okay and that would give you a lower
bound
circumflex
okay
um
so
so these kind of duals i think it was
providing some sort of
alternate universe where like the inputs
become the computational model like
you're testing like uh that your program
is like the set of labeled examples and
the circuits become the inputs and so
when you you flip it this way upper
bounds become lower bounds
and so then no then you
wonder well i mean of course everything
here is non-uniform okay so that
so i mean it's still not this we're not
i'm not saying that like algorithms
equal circuit complexities like that
because like again algorithms are
something that we design one of and then
we let it it will run on everything this
is still a non-uniform
notion of an algorithm giving you a
lower bound okay
all right
just like one yes like if f has a size s
circuit yes and you're able to like xor
with something yes you could make a
circuit
that's equal to f except on one point
yes and then you need yes that uh that
gives you at least one direction yes
yeah yeah yeah so let me
uh well okay so i have this example and
then then i'll say a little bit more
details so for example the following
things are equivalent
so um
np is not in p poly or maybe mp is not
infinitely often in p pi so uh not even
the case of rainfall meaning input links
you can get a polynomial size circuit
so that's this is a totally equivalent
to saying the following for every
epsilon and for amply mini s
okay or respectively for every s if you
want to prove that lower bound the data
complexity of testing sizes circuits for
sat is in most 2 to the s epsilon
so
proving np
not mp poly is equivalent to proving a
sub-exponential upper bound on the data
complexity of testing sat circuits so
i'll give you a circuit i want to know
does it solve the sat problem yes or no
okay it's of size s how many
how many examples of boolean formulas do
i need to give it before i can tell you
for sure whether i compute this that
problem or not on that slice okay this
is subexponential if and only if np is
not in people
okay
um
so so although we prove these kind of
generic statements
it's open as far as i know i mean if
whether we can use data complexity to
recover even
uh so recover say new proofs of say old
circuit lower bounds like take for
example
the proof
that parity
um the circuit complexity of parity on
and or and not
if n2 is exactly
three times n minus one
okay if you want to compute the parity
function on
on and
or and not so you want to compute
mod 2
so it's exactly this
so in principle
you should be able to give a data
complexity proof of this by giving some
upper bound on the data complexity some
some
sub-exponential upper bound the data
complexity that proves the lower bound
for this
so there's even giving any kind of proof
that uses this data complexity notion of
any circuit lower bound i think would be
interesting because
um it just seems like uh
you would think maybe okay you can just
recover it from the known proofs but uh
it's not it's not so it's not so easy
there is some loss in going between
these kind of two things
so the 3n minus 1
yeah this is for computing mod 2 with
and or not and fan into
oh ok so like for example on for two
variables it takes
an and of orders of two of variables and
we're not counting not gates it's just
answers
yeah with not coming for free the usual
the usual counting yeah that we do yeah
so this would be like you know some sort
of
baby example to try to understand what
data complex is doing sort of similar to
how like people are
trying to use like get just even the
basic sort of obstructions uh in
geometric complexity theory just to
recover you know small proofs
of lower bounds for uh matrix
multiplication
oh uh i think bryn moore can probably
prove something but i don't remember
what he proved like he he he ran some
computer search to sort of like find the
uh good uh data sets i think he proved
something but he really wanted to get
exactly that and so it's a little tricky
uh
yeah yeah is it obvious why you should
be parameterizing by the size of the
circuit and not like no it's not at all
obvious it looks weird
um
but it but it's sort of yeah like it's
sort of in retrospect it gives you
what you want like that but i mean
the intuition that
the like the intuition may be in
hindsight is that the input is the input
to the test com the testing problem is
of length roughly s
okay and so this is like as a function
of of the input
um
yeah
so it probably would even be nicer if
you actually said
the you know the optimal coding of an of
a
size s circuit
oh
it depends on what you i think you're
going to be involved
the number of circuits of on n inputs of
size s is going to come right into it
because you're going to look at like a
heart set yeah uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and to get the equivalence yes yes yes
yeah
yeah
just for a quick second
can you go back one slide yes
okay so i will state formal versions of
these things
um i believe in the next slide
if not i will skip the slide and
intensity it
uh let's see
so let let f would be as before and let
s say be at least like 2n just to make
things nice so this will be the circuit
size if you want so that again the data
complexity of testing sizes circuits for
f just to say it again it's the minimum
number of inputs needed to distinguish
circuits of size f computing a slice of
f
sorry compute serious s computing a
slice of f
circuits of size s that don't
okay just want to know the minimum
number of inputs of any potential size
so any potential number of them like if
this thing has n of c
we're going to have some inputs of
length n of c among these things
okay
okay so the first theorem is that if a
function f
has circuits of size s of n
okay then the data complexity of testing
sizes circuits for f
is to the omega s inverse of s
almost everywhere okay
so
basically when you impact this statement
it's
sort of like what russell was saying
i'll say more in a moment okay so
basically getting uh having a circuit
upper bound automatically gives you some
kind of lower bound on the a complexity
but you take the inverse of the function
here
and then
conversely if we manage to prove that f
is not in
size slightly larger than s of n
okay
then we can upper bound the data
complexity okay so the data complexity
of testing sizes circuits for f
is it most
order
two to this s of inverse s things is
some exponential thing
plus some small
polynomial in s well times this s of
inverse
okay infinitely often okay
so when you sort of go backwards and and
look
at the previous slides this basically is
saying things like if you've got a
function f
it's in p poly if and only if
its data complexity
is at least
2 to the s the epsilon for some
epsilon all right
um so i'll give some very
vague proof sketches of these things but
hopefully we'll at least get you started
thinking about how how these things
approved
okay
so here's some ideas right
so the first theorem looks a bit weird
but it actually has a really really
simple proof i mean it's really
really easy
so if you've got a function it has
circuits of size s of n
okay so it's already got certain sizes
then for every n bit input x
there's a circuit slightly larger say s
of n plus n which disagrees with f only
at x
okay this is like a pretty simple
exercise like the idea you have your
circuit of size s of n you have the sort
of exception case with n gates which
says oh if your input happens to be
exactly this x then just do the opposite
thing
okay so you just have these extra end
gates that do the opposite thing okay so
this says that
when um
so when you have this kind of upper
bound it's going to be very hard to test
uh whether the thing is computing
f or not
okay
so it follows from this that essentially
every test set for circuits of size
slightly larger than s of n say as in
placent is going to have cardinality at
least two to the n
because if you don't include like this
example x
in there
then
right then there's a circuit that could
get the rest of it right but get that
one wrong
okay
so
so having this
having the circuit upper bound for f
gives you some lower bound and says okay
you know if your circuit size s if like
um
right if if your second size is big
enough
that you can actually start to compute
this function f then you're going to try
all to the n inputs you have to put all
through the inputs
in in your test set and tell me what
what the value is on everything okay all
right so that's so that's the lower
bound
all right now to go the opposite
direction is a is a bit trickier okay so
here we want to say if you don't have
circuits slightly larger than s
then i can give you some nice sort of
counter example set that will allow you
to
to
test circuits for f
efficiently
okay
and so the idea behind this which
appears in in lots of different papers
actually
uh in in various uh ways maybe sometimes
implicitly
is that
if you have f
if f doesn't have circuits of size let's
say 2n times s of n
then for all circuits of size s of n so
this is a slightly smaller circuit size
you can get a small
test set that will because no circuit of
size s of n will compute f for sure
because f doesn't have even two n times
less than sine circuits but
moreover like because we chose s of n to
be strictly smaller than what we know
the lower bound to be we can in fact
have a small set of counter examples a
small set of x's and f of x's that will
fool
and we'll say rule out all circles of
size s of n
okay
so
there are various ways to prove this and
brent moore and i use this from a more
general theorem about
a zero-sum game between circuits and
inputs
yeah yeah but lipton and young also
prove something like this absolutely
yeah
now for size s circuits so so i'm just
trying to say more intuition about these
two theorems here okay so for sizes
circuits where the number of inputs in
is sort of too large to compute the
function so right you imagine the
circuit size s is fixed now so whether
or not i'm going to be able to compute a
slice of f actually depends on the
number of inputs to that circuit not not
the size okay so if this if right if the
number of inputs are like log of the
size then i can always compute the
function right every
i mean every function
has 2 to the n size series okay so if
the number of inputs is too large to
compute f if it's too large would mean
the circuit is small as the number of
functions of inputs we have small test
sets that's what this thing says we get
the small counter example family okay
and we include all those small test sets
that's where you get this extra n
squared so our s squared factor here
then for sizes circuits where n is small
enough where it's really small and we
and
once they become small enough we can
actually compute a slice of f
then
well it becomes possible to compute f
sizes and then we have to include all
possible inputs
so so the way this thing is saying is
that
like your test set your minimum test is
going to look like the following when
the
when n is small enough you're going to
have all possible
inputs labeled examples up to a certain
point where you're reaching the circuit
complexity okay once n gets large enough
you can start having sort of polynomial
size test sets as a in terms of the
circuit size that will that will
distinguish okay
and so overall like you're more or less
pinning down things exactly with a
certain complexity happens yeah
can you sort of like relate this to the
vc dimension of size s circuits oh
because well you know if
it's basically saying you know the vc
dimension of size s circuits is about s
log s
and um
so like there's a set of inputs
on which um
knowing the values on that input
um
determine which which circuit which
function you know if it is computable by
size s yeah it determines exactly which
function it is
yeah i mean yeah it's something
something like that so yeah sort of
right around the circuit complexity you
go from like having to
include all two to the n possible
examples to having to only include a
polynomial number of examples of the
function of circuit size yeah
so that this is the
the the basic idea behind how you prove
this um
yeah but you feel free to you know
ask me uh later and in person more about
it
so i guess i want to conclude with some
uh general questions to think more about
about these things so how can algorithms
help prove lower balance so how can
properties of circuits be turned into
algorithms for for analyzing them
okay
and how can lower bounds help design
algorithms okay so we've seen
at least an eye level lots of different
examples of these two kinds of things
and so
the whole thesis here is that we can
make progress
uh on both algorithms and lower bounds
by studying them as a unit not as sort
of two separate things but as things
that sort of naturally relate to each
other and you know when you prove a
lower bound in one way it can give you
an algorithm for a different kind of
thing and they seem much more related
than sort of the artificial uh
boundaries we've drawn from them and
then in the next lecture i'll give you
an explicit example of this and
hopefully lots of detail uh that mainly
the proof that nx was not in acc okay
and i'll stop here for today
so
in the case of
of uh use that you had of raspberry
spalensky sort of
you could at one sense say
well that was kind of
a lucky accident their proof technique
happened to be useful for all of these
problems it it proved more than somehow
is is necessary
really and you know maybe it used did
much more than was necessary to actually
prove the circuit separation
and i don't know what your take is on
sort of thinking about yeah well there
are more examples than just roswell from
smolinski
yeah i mean like random the random
restriction
and all the new ideas have been gone
have gone into proving concentration
bounds there have you know given new set
algorithms for lots of different classes
we didn't know anything for so
i mean it's possible the random
restriction stuff could be applied in a
similar broad way i i don't
i don't know i mean but yeah
i guess but even there you could say oh
well you know they were proving
something stronger than what they really
needed whatever
yeah
i don't know um i mean at least
even in the black box way we have some
equivalences sort of saying that you've
got to have at least this kind of weak
algorithm with all these like provisos
and stuff whereas i'm not sure anyone's
going to actually look for algorithms
exactly all those little properties
they're going to try and get out that's
like maybe not infinitely often because
who knows what you could do anything
just do it almost everywhere and like
okay i don't know what advice to pick so
i'm not going to use it bison so maybe
i'll prove a lower bound that way in
fact that's sort of how the acc lower
bound goes
so i mean it might just be that you know
maybe we're not doing the minimum
necessary to prove lower bounds but
that's just because
maybe even finding that is like harder
than just getting something that works
using algorithmic thinking and designing
lower bounds
yeah yeah
yeah
so to me it seems that the the general
principle is that
you get a circuit which is
small and
and you use the property that it is
small to
do something with the circuit and make
it even much much simpler so either you
write it by random restriction and you
get very simple things yeah or you just
approximate it and you get simple things
which are polynomials yeah this
should help to solve algorithmic
problems
of well if this is a general form of
your problem at the bottom then yeah
yeah method will give you a speed up
yeah uh
can this be formalized into a meta
theorem like if your problem is for each
pair do a computation of this form then
yeah so what would the form of
computation be like just an ac 0 circle
oh yeah um it could even be like you
know an acc circuit you could probably i
mean you could
take i mean it's hard to figure out like
what what is like the max uh maxima of
this like set of like you know what is
the strongest circuit but there are lots
of different results and yeah sort of
any time you have
this kind of circuit that you can put in
some nice polynomial like form which
makes it easy to evaluate either by
matrix malt or by an fft then you
if this is like some compu just sort of
some repeated subcomputation going on
there
then yeah you can you can sort of do
this repeated sub computation many times
by using the fact that matrix
multiplication can do repeated sub
computation many times
efficiently you know sort of it's just
you know kind of a reduction
bootstrapping of the fact that in matrix
multiplication you're doing a bunch of
inner products
uh efficiently all together
um but it's really sort of
identifying a bottleneck like this so
for all pairs shortest paths let's say
in the real ram it's not all clear like
what your bottleneck computation is but
you kind of unpack like things and you
use like fredman's trick and all this
stuff from the previous wallpaper
shortest path you do get some kind of
circuit that's
you can think of as being
computed many many times
over and yeah anytime you have this kind
of repeated sim computation you can
speed up that part of it at least
just kind of fft like thing right uh
yeah i mean sort of for circuits it's
like a decomposition for circuits which
makes them
yeah like it makes it possible to
evaluate the circuit on many points uh
fast faster than just trying each one
russell you had a question
is there any way you could view this see
it's not a meta algorithm
but
is there some kind of like meta
algorithm like circuits ad for depth 2
um ac 0 you know
threshold circuits of a given kind
yeah that
you could view this as a reduction too
yeah yeah i mean and depending on you
know my mood when i was writing the
paper i either wrote it that way or it
didn't i mean like yeah um
i mean in
in general it's like you
uh the
like the
prince the basic principle behind all
these things is that you have some
repeated some computation it's got two
kinds of inputs let's say x and y inputs
and
and and the circuit is restricted in
some particular form some form that we
knew how to analyze thanks to lots of
circuit complexity work
um yeah and then it then the theorem is
that you can
evaluate the circuit on all pairs of
inputs like say one from one set like n
and one from another set and
in time
about n squared you know here we're sort
of shrinking it so that these are n over
s and these are n over s
yeah there's certainly
this very generic statement sitting
underneath it all yeah